clock gets six
harris throws it up rebound feel
up ahead here comes westbrook down by
two westbrook
to the hoop with the laptop tough
tough
38 for westbrook
irving the free-throw line jumper
brooklyn back
on top by two and scott brooks will call
his final timeout
of the game this is looking a lot like
the game back on january
third back and forth a two-point game
now with 30.5 seconds to go
russell westbrook is an assist away from
a triple double and he's got
38 points
i mean he has put this team on his back
along with bradley beal
and forced the issue but kyrie irving
talk about
isolation guys and this is honestly i
think what
all wizards fans and nba fans were
looking forward to this year with
westbrook and beale
westbrook has 38. beal's got 32
they are putting this team on chris
green brown
and irving russell westbrook being one
assist shot for a triple-double
hopefully he could get it on this play
deal
step back for the tie and the rebound by
green and there's the foul by westbrook
beal had a great
look at it there's still a lot of time
though
23.3 seconds
sometimes you're just too old right
and bradley beal i know he wishes he
could have this one back but great
decision got
kd on the right back
great recovery by kevin durant to get
that
shot contested but bradley beal i know
he wish he could have that back
jeff green almost an 86 percent free
throw shooter four for four tonight
he's got a season high and 22 points
and he misses the first so now the
wizards can still tie
if he hits this one with a three no
timeouts remaining if he missed
it's off to the races your best play
is attacking the nets while their
defense is not balanced
so if this is a miss get out and run
[Applause]
three-point game here's beale
back to westbrook westbrook for three
no batons can't control the rebound
and it's brooklyn ball with 14 seconds
and the wahoo cabaret is going to come
in i imagine for brown
and that's what happens this way you get
a better free throw shooter in
they get it to irving he wants to get
fouled there it is
kyrie irving three of three at the line
he's got 24 points
and that foul against bertons is going
to be his
sixth
[Applause]
we've had opportunities neal had a
chance
for the tie westbrook had a chance for
the tie with a three
and now irving at the line to give
brooklyn
a potential five-point lead
[Applause]
he has missed only three free throws all
season long
five-point game 12.3 they got to go
quick
[Applause]
beal will pull up for three he hits it
35 for bo two point game matthews with a
steal
here's westbrook for three
[Applause]
are you kidding me talk about a turn
of events
down by five and they score six
in a span of seven seconds
[Applause]
unbelievable
[Applause]
here's brad right here with the pull-up
great shot
and this is what i like right here look
at garrison here garrison matthews
get that to russell westbrook put a
three i mean
did that just happen
they haven't even put the three points
on the board for westbrook he should
have 41
and the wizards have a one point lead
again
[Music]
irving is trying to direct traffic right
now
bonga on the inbounds 2.9 irving can't
move that should have been to travel
[Applause]
there's a foul hang on there is a foul
i believe there's time on the clock
they're going to look at this but that
should have been a travel on westbrook
he can
excuse me on irving he clearly moved on
the inbounds
are they going to say this is basket
interference
needs to set it up of course and you can
see
coach brooks probably signaling that
he gets it to go he was trying to miss
only seven tenths of a second don't foul
harris to inbound durant doesn't get it
off in time and the wizards are gonna
win this one
149 146
unbelievable the best win
of the season and to think about this
drew gooden
two of their four wins are against the
brooklyn nets this year
big wins
[Applause]
bradley beal finishes with 37. russell
westbrook finishes with 41